hello my name is Craig Spencer I am a
physician an aid worker for doctors
without borders also known as MSF I am
very proud to be among the ranks of more
than 3,500 providers working with
Doctors Without Borders to respond to
the Ebola outbreak in West Africa I
wanted to start by taking a moment to
thank the medical team here at hhc
bellevue hospital center for the
tremendous care and support they have
provided to me to survive this virus
since I was admitted on october 23rd i
received an exceptional level of medical
treatment support and encouragement from
the whole medical and administrative
team I would especially like to thank
dr. Laura Evans who has primary who has
primarily managed my care since I first
arrived and has been with me every
single day today I am healthy and no
longer infectious my early detection
reporting and now recovery from Ebola
speaks to the effectiveness of the
protocols that are in place for health
staff returning from West Africa I am a
living example of how those protocols
work and of how early detection is
critical to both surviving Ebola and
ensuring that it is not transmitted to
others well my case has garnered
international attention it is important
to remember that my infection represents
but a fraction of the more than 13,000
reported cases to date in West Africa
the center of the outbreak where
families are being torn apart in
communities are destroyed it is for this
reason that I volunteered to work in
Guinea with Doctors Without Borders for
over five weeks I worked in a noble a
treatment center in kakadu the epicenter
of the outbreak during this time I cried
as I held children who are not strong
enough to survive the virus
but I also experienced immense joy when
patients I treated were cured and
invited me into their family as a
brother upon discharge within a week of
my diagnosis many of these same patients
called my personal cell phone from
Guinea to wish me well and asked if
there was any way that they could
contribute to my care most incredibly I
watched my guinean colleagues who have
been on the front line since day one and
have seen their friends and family
members die as they continue to fight to
save the communities their communities
with so much compassion and dignity they
are the true heroes that we are not
talking about please join me in turning
our attention back to West Africa and
ensuring that medical volunteers and
other aid workers do not face stigma and
threats upon their return home
volunteers need to be supported to help
fight this outbreak at its source I'm
immensely thankful for all of the
encouragement and support that I've
received from my family so many friends
and complete strangers over the past few
weeks in addition I would like to thank
my home institution Columbia University
Medical Center for the unprecedented
support I've received from the time I
decided to deploy until after my
diagnosis lastly I would like to
publicly recognize my incredibly deep
appreciation for doctors without borders
I cannot begin to mention how well they
have helped manage this difficult time
for both myself and my family finally I
would like to thank in advance the media
for respecting my right and my family's
right to complete privacy I will not be
commenting publicly beyond the statement
and I urge you please to focus your
attention where is most urgently needed
at the source of the Ebola outbreak in
West Africa thank you